a clash at sea
causing waves of international concern a
russian military ship rams into a
ukrainian tugboat off the coast of
crimea
the vessel was later fired at and
captured by the russians along with two
other ships
and dozens of ukrainian seamen several
of whom were injured
the united nations security council held
an emergency meeting
where western countries accused russia
of stoking an already deadly war with
ukraine
what we witnessed this weekend is yet
another reckless
russian escalation it is an arrogant act
that the international community must
condemn and will never
accept in response russia's
representative said the ukrainian ship
had violated
its territorial waters moscow says the
incident was a provocation by ukrainian
president petro poroshenko
to boost his support in upcoming
elections
in kiev poroshenko has declared a state
of martial law for 30 days
but insisted it would not interfere with
the looming presidential vote
in brussels nato secretary general
warned russia that its actions would
have consequences
there is no justification for the use of
military force
against ukrainian ships and naval
personnel
so we call on russia to release
immediately
the ukrainian sailors and ships it
ceased
yesterday and we call for
calm and restraint
sea traffic is again flowing through the
disputed waters
after russia briefly blocked the crucial
passage
but moscow says it will continue to hold
the ukrainian ships and sailors
while it conducts its own investigation
this outrageous violation of sovereign
ukrainian territory
is part of a pattern of russian behavior
that includes the purported annexation
of crimea
and abuses against countless ukrainians
in crimea
as well as stoking conflict that has
taken the lives
of more than 10 000 people in eastern
ukraine
further escalation of the situation by
the russian federation should not be
ruled out
according to available intelligence data
there is a clear threat for invasion
and seizing of marijuana and bergensk
further aggressive acts and provocations
by the fsb
border guard service and russian navy
remains a realistic possibility
what kiev has been doing in coordination
with the united states and others
to promote a conflict line against
russia is fraught with very dangerous
consequences
we are going to curb any infringement of
russian sovereignty and territorial
integrity
including the sea of azov and that area
we do hope that is clear
well for more on this story we're joined
now by our dw correspondent nick
connolly in kiev
and emily sherwin in moscow good morning
to you both
nick ukraine has imposed martial law
what kinds of power
does this give ukrainian authorities and
how will that help them solve this
crisis
good morning terry well this is
unprecedented in all the years of
conflict we've seen here in ukraine
after the annexation by russia of crimea
and the conflict in the east this has
never happened before this is
a first um basically this gives the
government the option to restrict civil
liberties anything from freedom of
speech
to freedom of assembly giving the police
more powers and also potentially
allowing for the
mobilization of army reservists having
said that
we still haven't seen much detail this
was voted through
late last night in pretty chaotic
parliamentary
assembly it wasn't clear for a long time
if it would actually get the
numbered required number of votes it did
but whether this is just an option the
government is giving itself
for the case of further escalation with
russia or if we're going to see a direct
impact on everyday ukrainians lives we
still don't know and this is
what will come out of today really emily
in moscow
uh western nations are calling on russia
to release the ukrainian sailors and
ships that has seized is that likely to
happen
well terry it doesn't seem like there
will be a concession on that issue from
russia any time
soon especially because russia considers
that it captured
those vessels and those sailors
absolutely legally they
absolutely here in russia see that they
acted correctly and according to russian
and international law in fact the
russian side has very much been
categorizing what happened
as a ukrainian invasion um you have to
remember that russia considers the azov
sea to be
russian waters after the annexation of
crimea in 2014 which of course
ukraine does not recognize and uh russia
has also been categorizing ukraine as
the aggressor in this situation
yesterday we saw a statement
from the fsb the russian security
services saying that actually
um it was the ukrainian vessels that
pointed their guns
at the russian vessels first um and
threatened them um so very much uh
russia categorizing
ukraine as being in the wrong and
ukraine as being the aggressor here so i
don't think any concessions on the crew
and the vessels
that were captured anytime soon terry
so nick as emily points out russia
regards what happened there
as a ukrainian invasion explain to us
how the disputed waterway we're talking
about here is shared
and why it's so important to ukraine
well terry obviously before the russian
annexation of crimea in 2014
you had ukrainian controlled crimea on
the western side of the strait and then
the russian mainland on the eastern side
and they shared control
over this waterway to the sea of azov
which then also
obviously is shared by ukraine by
um ukrainian ports like mariupol and
then the russian side
since russia took over crimea basically
they have also
had de facto control over access to sea
of azov
something that ukraine and the west
obviously do not recognize but this is
crucial not just for crimea this is not
just something
about sovereignty in an abstract sense
this is also about
donbass about the other conflict that
ukraine has with russia
because tens of thousands of jobs depend
on the ports on the sea of azov
being able to get trade in and out if
it's this seed turns into a military
zone
with no real access from outside that
could really destabilize the situation
in the east of ukraine
where it had seemed in recent months
that things had become calmer and more
stable